okay hi everyone uh thank you for
joining my talk and this uh ignite
session that we're going to have uh this
is my first uh ignite about technical
documentation and I'm going to talk
about a how to write them better and why
should I care and when I say I I of
course also mean you so first of all hi
my name is hila fish I'm senior devop
engineer and I work for weeks I have
years of experience in tech industry I
can say a lot of things about myself but
I only have 15 minutes to cover this
massive topic so let's get right to it
so I think that everyone can and should
write technical documents because in the
middle of the night when I only have
like an incident that I don't know
anything about because it is something
that my team member implemented or
something like that the only thing that
I care about is that I have runbook that
helps me fix the issue or at least tell
me what to check and if I have it that's
great I don't care about anything else I
don't read this document and say oh this
English is so bad who wrote it I don't
care the only thing that I care is that
awesome I have a rook that helps me fix
the issue and this is only one example
and I will cover more examples of why
it's important to write technical
documentation but it's basically about
sharing knowledge so that's why I really
think that everyone can and should write
technical documentation to share the
knowledge with
everyone I also like to say that if you
can't automate it then document it and a
lot things that you can do in your
day-to-day can be documented so the
straightforward thing is to H write
about system logical design or brief
this is the straightforward one but
there are other things like Onan books
as I just mentioned code rhms to
incorporate and explain any intentions
reasoning a spaghetti code any functions
that are not clear onboarding docs why
uh assign a body to a new member in the
team if they can have one boarding Dock
and then just on board themselves
project planning doc sometimes we have
massive projects that we need to
document uh in order to understand
what's the status and what are the
botton legs and stuff like that and even
slack pin messages if you have a
knowledge you can share it about
anything and if it's it fits a slack pin
message that people will daily use then
H do it and I'm not saying that you have
to um like utilize and engage in all of
these uh examples here but at least if
you do a few then it will be much more
helpful and useful for anyone around you
okay question for you people have you
ever heard this sentence or said this
this sentence
before raise your hand come on come on
don't lie don't lie come on okay so a
lot of people in my career in other
people career that where that I talked
about with uh they said that they heard
the sentence or heard the sentence
before that my code is s the doent
because the code tells the story or just
read the code and understand what it is
about no it's not the case it never is
the case you know that so we always need
to understand what the code is about
explain spaghetti code explain
reasonings intentions and all the things
that I'm going to cover in the next
slide uh and basically help us H do our
job much more uh
easier so let's understand why should we
write technical documents first of all
to reduce your work volume and you can
say wait use if I sit down and write
documents it waste time and not reduce
my work volume so let me explain what I
mean uh in my previous company since I'm
a devop engineer I got approached by QA
people developers saying like hey why is
my pod red in kubernetes and how do I
troubleshoot it what is this error when
I deploy the cicd pipeline all these
kind of things and then people approach
me like I I don't think seven or eight
times a day easily and the questions
were some of them were very repetitive
so I gathered all the repetitive
questions I created a document called it
tips and tricks by devops I to give them
gave them the the document and then
after that from magically from seven or
eight times a day they got a decreased
to one or two times a day so that's what
was great and helped me reduce my work
volume because I need to support less H
incidents H after after that it also
helps with self-service Enon example of
this dock once I H deploy this dock to
their custody like let's call it like
that then they helped themselves with
troubleshooting they could do things on
their own so it helped with their
self-service and increased their Dev
velocity another example for that is a
onboarding stocks that I mentioned
before people can onboard themselves a i
migrated in my previous company I
immigrated um gitlab from Cloud to self
hosted so I created a doc for H how to
adopt the tool faster because they don't
know the tool before so this also helped
them for self-service and to increase
their velocity so a lot of things can be
considered uh things that could help
with these
two eliminate production incidents
quicker as I mentioned before if we have
run books we can eliminate incidents and
back to sleep uh much more quickly and
also decrease meantime to
resolution avoid single point of failure
or a Buton L which is you because I will
ask you this rhetorical question do you
want to go on vacation and still be
available for work calls or they want to
go to have a clear mind so that's that
and also I would say it here job
security is dead okay don't batttle up
the the knowledge share the knowledge
some people say hey I will take take our
jobs anyway let's prevent it from doing
it by sharing the knowledge between us
human
beings um it will help make things clear
for you or the future you because once
you structure things and write them down
in a clear manner it will organize it in
your mind as well and also anything
about intentions reasoning anything that
is not straightforward as I mentioned
before the code is not self-documented
please document it because it will help
you your future you and your team
members all around you visibility it
will attract Focus to the things that
you do at work H which in turn will help
progress your career and also it will
help you communicate things to your
managers the extent of your work and to
to convey that you are an actual team
player not just something that you write
in your
CV and last but not least it will help
you understand why we're doing things in
a certain way so if we cover things like
why did I set certificates here or how
do I renew certificates or why did the
model is complex and why did I wrote the
code in a certain way that doesn't
follow clean code practices like clean
like dry and kiss all of these kind of
things will help us basically defend the
decisions that we are taking and
communicate them H to others it will
also develop your business mindset and
will make you better engineer because
always asking why will strive for the
best solution imple implementation
possible I hope that I convinced you
until now that writing to techn
technical documents is good now let's
see how to write them in a in a simple
manner without being a technical writer
first of all you need to be to know your
audience we have two types of audiences
internal use system design and external
use API documentation stuff like that if
we know our audience it's a based on our
audience we will know what needs to be
covered and to which
extent so for internal use we should
write about things that you worked on
while working on them H things that
bugged you in the git migration that I
mentioned uh I covered in the document a
section of how to open support tickets
without having a ping pong with us in
support because I had a h several
tickets that I opened after 3 days give
us logs okay and it's always the same
logs they ask they have the CLI that
generates logs great so I documented it
and next time whenever someone opens a
ticket they will automatically attach
the the logs and then uh we saved three
time three days of ping pong so anything
that bugged you that could help others
preventing H them to to see that as well
we should cover it as well things that
aren't clear on straightforward I said
it before I will say it again anything
that is not straightforward the G
migration that I did another example
about that I used a DB version that is
different from the default why did I do
that I had a very good reason to do that
if I don't cover it in the
recommendation people will think ah it's
a mistake H she didn't notice whatever
and they will override it and it wasn't
good because it was for future H
versions um support so anything of this
sort should be H documented as well for
external use you should cover H what is
the thing that you are writing about
possible use cases and quick start any
quirks issues things to consider when
using this x examples both simple and
complex that will help the user adopt
whatever you're talking about because we
want to make sure the user will use the
thing that we are actually talking
about second phase decide oride upon
documentation type some people use a dox
in knowledge bases like Confluence and
some already moved to dox's code which I
will cover in this presentation if you
can decide to move to dox's code after
seeing this presentation you will see
that is it is good that's great if not
and you need to stay with knowledge base
that's okay too but you will see that
you have still things to make it better
as it is let's cover some general
content guidelines for any talks if they
are knowledge based or in h code so
first of all your doc should have table
of contents it is essential for Content
Discovery and why is that because of the
user flow I've read a found an article
from 1997 saying that people don't read
they scan and it's still the case and
until this very day people not read this
is the user flow okay they search for
something so that's why you should have
meaningful titles and subheadings and
then once they found something that they
looks good to them they scan the
document if they found what they are
looking for they will go to the result
if not they will navigate elsewhere so
that's why you should have links to any
other documents that could be helpful
for the user and then navigate them to
this area and then for help them scheme
the the document and the search uh ER
results much more quickly highlights put
anything that is important in bold and
uh in terms of colors it could be
sometimes controversial but I found that
using colors is very good even if some
people are color blind or accessibility
issues issues other can still use it and
I found that developers say ah yeah now
that it's in red I know not to touch it
for example so sometimes using um colors
is the way to go use short words and
more sentences rather than longer words
and fewer sentences because it will help
users scheme the documents much more
quickly uh backed up by I don't know if
by studies but it is backed up H and
please please please write simple
English that H non-english native
speakers could easily understand don't
try to be Shakespeare okay simple
English this is the way to go it will be
much more helpful and not oh what is
this world let me look it up once you
have an incident and you need to deal
with the incident and not just check the
word in the vocabulary So Right Use
simple
English doxis code so why doxis code is
so great it is using a markdown which
means that you still can utilize table
of contents and highlights and even
colors it is plain text so it is human
readable it is easy to write and diff
and it is platform agnostic so it
doesn't matter which platform you're
using you can incorporate a doxes code
inside it also means that the document
folder is in the same code reper which
means that the docs are integrated in
the dev tool chain and there's no need
for the developers to leave the IDE and
which it's awesome because developers
like their ID they like to write code
you know what I'm saying so if we can
allow them to do that let's do
that H utilizing doses code also allows
us to have PR review for documents so we
can check hey the document didn't get
updated once the function get updated or
any anything of this sort or even
there's no document H attached so for
any test that you can think of you can
have a PR check and then if the test
didn't H pass the pr will fail to merge
and then the the developer will have to
add document will have to update the the
document which is awesome for the day
to-day
maintenance also cicd you can have cicd
H integration for checking validations
and then there are no broking uh links
and LS and stuff like that there are two
tools that I know about that help help
with this and other features doos sarus
and swim I haven't used them myself but
I'm sure that if you will check them out
maybe they will fit your use case and of
course I I assume there are other tools
that you can check out as well but the
idea here is to utilize tools that we
help you H maintain docks in day-to-day
as opposed to having them stale and not
up to dat last phase remember your
audience okay we we talked about knowing
your audience now we need to remember
them so based on who you are talking to
you you need to have the user flow in
mind in and between sections and to
write the document order from the most
used to rarely used for for example if I
write a a document for my team members
of how to maintain gitlab then I need to
first talk about how to upgrade because
they will do it frequently then
certificates because they will do it
only once in two years and then
Integrations that they will do only once
they deploy gitlab from scratch so have
the user flow in mind and then based on
that write document
concept versus tasks this is also super
important you need to think and convey
the audience that you show that show
them that you know what they're thinking
about so if they want to do something if
they want to know something Concepts
then you need to have the document cover
information background explanations
reasoning intentions stuff like that but
if they want to do something tasks then
you should cover a how to in this
document and please don't confuse the
two because at a certain point a user
always always wants to do something they
want to do something or they want to
know something it doesn't H happen at
the same time so if it's a how to Great
put a link to the info document if it's
a a concept great now link to how to do
it with this links then you can help the
user find whatever they are looking for
but always a document should be one
thing at a time think about like a
microservice does only one thing and
then it communicates with other
documents other microservices so don't
confuse the two
H last phase is to share the document
with others because sometimes you write
things and it looks straightforward to
you but it's not really straightforward
for them uh what is this initials what
is the flow I don't know this flow stuff
like that and remember this document is
for your audience so you need to share
it with your audience get feedbacks do
some iterations and make the document as
useful as possible for your
audience and last but not least I told
you that this document this presentation
is about WR technical documentation
without being a technical writer but if
you still want to have some writing tips
of how to structure documents how to
write in in a way that will help the
users H understand better and stuff like
that I gathered some H tips from myself
and from technical writer
Joshua gaser who is um a colleague of
mine in Wix so I'm going to populate it
on the go but these are great tips that
we covered here so basically that's it
and probably would say hey this
presentation is very short and you
talked very very quickly I don't
understand what what you talk about
because it's very very quickly at least
take this H goal and rule in mind which
is provide readers with the information
they need and send them back to their
task as soon as possible and make sure
that documentation should always be
clear simple and to the point and if you
say the clicker is very quick if you say
um if you say that I don't have the time
to integrate any new tools and I want to
have like a immediate um impact right
now how can we do it how can we have a
method method it's a very hard word
methodology uh to upgrading updating
that tasks sorry updating documents on a
day-to-day basis then what should you do
have the documentation an integral part
of a task aka the developer the QA the
UI whoever can't close the ticket unless
the the documentation was added H to the
feature or whatever they are working for
and that way you make sure the task the
the documents are up to date in a
day-to-day manner so I really hope that
after this seeing this presentation you
will go back to your day-to-day job
update some documents and then you will
say that your code is now well
documented thank
[Applause]
you